[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the fast Fourier transform and how you
can transform data vectors into their
Fourier coefficients and now I'm going
to tell you how you can use the FFT to
approximate derivatives in this Python
example okay so in this example what
we're gonna do is take a function where
we know the derivative we can
analytically compute the exact
derivative and we're going to compare
how accurate the FFT is compared to that
analytic derivative and we're also going
to compare this against the simple
finite difference derivative that you
would kind of normally do on data okay
so in this in this Python code we have
some some some data we're going to
define on a range L so the length of our
domain is going to be 30 and we're gonna
define our data from minus L over 2 to L
over 2 minus 15 to 15 our function is
going to be this cosine function times
this this decaying Gaussian function so
it's basically a cosine in a Gaussian
envelope and we can analytically compute
the derivative DF using the chain rule
here so that's the perfect derivative
machine precision and now what we're
gonna do is we're going to approximate
that derivative using both a finite
difference scheme kind of a the simplest
thing you could think of and using the
FFT or the spectral derivative and we're
going to compare how accurate they are
now this isn't kind of as exhaustive as
you could possibly get the finite
difference derivative is a really really
crude derivative so here I'm literally
going to approximate the derivative at
step K is going to be approximated by
our function at k plus 1 the the K plus
1 element minus FK divided by Delta X we
know that this is not a very good
approximation of the derivative this has
error that scales like Delta X order
Delta X error I could do a better job
with like a central difference or a
higher order finite difference but this
is really just to illustrate you know a
another way you could compute things ok
so that's what we're doing here the
really important part is is down here
how we actually compute the derivative
using the FFT and we always called this
this
spectral derivative so here's what you
do the first thing is you take the FFT
of your function f in f hat and remember
if I took the Fourier transform so we've
already talked about this for continuous
functions if I take the Fourier
transform of the derivative of a
function with respect to X we know that
we can write that in terms of the
product of I times the frequencies times
the Fourier transform of F so this is I
times sometimes I write this as Omega
here I'm going to write this as Kappa
times the Fourier transform of F or if
you like I times Kappa times F hat and
I'm just gonna make a note down here I
use Kappa when I'm Fourier transforming
in space so these are spatial
frequencies spatial frequencies
sometimes called wave numbers okay
you're gonna hear wave numbers or
spatial frequencies Kappa is a vector of
spatial frequencies and I usually use
Omega when I'm for you transforming in
time so this is space Omega is FM from
Fourier transforming in time so we used
Omega before when we did DF DT Omega
would be temporal frequencies okay but
basically kind of a they play the same
role it's just what I call them if I
Fourier transform in space I often call
those frequencies Kappa instead of Omega
I just wanted to point that out so this
is what you would do if you were working
with the continuous Fourier transform or
Fourier series but it's a little bit
more interesting in the in the data case
if I have a vector of data and I'm doing
the FFT then this F hat is actually a
vector of frequencies sorry a vector of
Fourier coefficients and Kappa is a
vector of frequencies and so what you
would do in the DFT world or in the FFT
world is you would take I Kappa 1 f1 hat
Kappa 2 f2 hat and so on and so forth
and take every frequency and multiply it
by its corresponding Fourier coefficient
and create a vector of you know
frequency weighted for EA coefficients
times I and if I inverse for you
transformed this vector if I took the
IFFT of this I would recover the
derivative of my data at those discrete
sample points okay so that's exactly
what what this is doing here I take the
the FFT and I put it in effort I create
this kappa vector which is basically a
big vector of frequencies so I take my
kind of fundamental frequency unit two
PI over L and I multiply it by this this
vector four minus n over 2 2 n over 2
and in most languages you have to be
careful about how you order and how you
organize those frequencies into that
Kappa vector so in most languages like
MATLAB and Python there's this fft shift
command so if you define your your
frequencies this way you run this fft
shift command and it orders them in the
same ordering that's consistent with how
it orders the frequencies in the fast
Fourier transform this is always a
little confusing it's kind of a mess
every language organizes these
frequencies differently and so basically
you just have to remember these two
lines of code you create a vector of
frequencies from minus n over 2 to n
over 2 in these fundamental units and
then you run the FFT shift command and
it'll reorder those into the right
ordering of frequencies that that's just
to make sure that those Kappas are
apples to apples with what those
frequencies in F hat correspond to ok
but once you do that it's really easy to
compute the derivative it's just Kappa
times f hat times the square root of
negative 1 this this unit imaginary
number here 1 J and then to get my
derivative in real spatial units I just
take the IFFT the inverse FFT of this
this derivative I Kappa F hat ok and the
upshot here is that all of these steps
are very fast and very accurate okay so
the FFT I can rapidly compute its order
n log n I can create this Kappa vector
no problem it's a little bit can
using that you just run these two lines
and you get a kappa vector then you can
compute your derivative it's AI times
Kappa times F and then you inverse
Fourier transform to get the derivative
back in spatial units okay and because
these are complex numbers in f hat when
you multiply these out and inverse
Fourier transform you might have very
very small machine precision imaginary
parts so we're just going to take the
real part of this inverse Fourier
transform that's just being careful and
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
plot the analytic derivative of my
function my finite difference derivative
of my function and my Fourier transform
spectral derivative of my function and
that's what we're doing down here
so in white you see the the true
derivative this is the machine precision
analytic derivative and then finite
difference in yellow and FFT in red and
you see very clearly that the red the
the the spectral derivative using the
FFT almost perfectly agrees with the
true analytic derivative whereas my
finite difference deviates quite
significantly it's really you know
there's a lot of error in my my yellow
curve here because we know that this
finite difference is not not very
accurate okay so this was not meant to
be super quantitative or exhaustive
actually in our book data-driven science
and engineering you can find it at
databook u-dub calm and in the links we
actually go through this example a
little bit more exhaustively and so I'm
just gonna walk you through this here so
this is actually a more careful
study as you increase the number of data
points in your signal which is the same
as decreasing Delta X as you make Delta
X smaller or n bigger it is absolutely
true that this finite difference
derivative does get more accurate but it
gets more accurate very slowly okay
whereas our spectral derivative our FFT
derivative gets more accurate very very
rapidly the more points I include in my
data the smaller Delta X is this FFT
based derivative gets much more accurate
and much more rapidly and so you can
tell that this error is on a log plot
and so I get maybe you know six or seven
orders of magnitude increase in the
error by just quadrupling the number of
points okay or even yeah quadrupling or
doubling the number of points so it's
really really data efficient to compute
these very accurate derivatives using
the the FFT but not using finite
differences and I would actually
encourage you to write up a code to do
this yourself all it would require is
taking this code I just show you showed
you and wrapping the four loop around it
for increasing n and making these plots
and you could then try higher order
accurate maybe a central different
scheme or a second order or a fourth
order find a different scheme and you
can see that those will in fact converge
faster but they won't converge as
rapidly as the spectral derivative the
spectral derivative is really a much
better way of computing the derivatives
of clean of clean data okay
so very nice we're gonna use this
property to compute the derivatives for
solving PDEs one more thing I want to
show you and this is also in Chapter two
of our book is what happens if you apply
this to a function like the the point e
the pointy hat function we looked at
earlier so even though F is continuous
here its derivative is discontinuous so
the derivative of F is zero then it
jumps to positive maybe 1 or 1/2 then it
jumps to negative 1/2 and then it jumps
back to zero at the end and so the
discontinuous derivative and when I use
the FFT to compute the derivative of
this function I get an approximate
derivative that has the right features
but you can see that this Gibbs
phenomenon is creeping back in ok so
because our derivative is discontinuous
when I use the spectral derivative it's
gonna have that Gibbs phenomenon in it
so you have to be really careful the FFT
is great for spectral derivatives of
smooth functions whose derivatives are
continuous ok so you have to have the
derivative be continuous or else you'll
get this Gibbs phenomenon ok good so in
the next few lectures we're going to
talk about how to use the FFT to solve
partial differential equations taking
advantage of this fast efficient
accurate derivative calculation ok thank
you